>> Greg: YESTERDAY AS CNN
BECAME NOSY, DETESTABLE NEIGHBOR
FROM "BEWITCHED."
JAMMING UP PHONY CONCERN ONLY TO
SPREAD MALICIOUS GOSSIP.
CHECK OUT THIS TWEET FROM OUR
NATIONS HALL MONITOR.
"IF ANY FIRST LADY DISAPPEARED,
YOU WOULD WANT TO KNOW WHERE SHE
IS."
TO JUSTIFY THE ODIOUS PREMISE,
HE FIRST HAD TO CREATE THE
PREMISE.
IF ANY FIRST LADY DISAPPEARED,
AND SO BEGINS A TROJAN HORSE FOR
A GHOULISH GAME ALL TO PUSH A
PHONY CNN SEGMENT.
INSTEAD OF SAYING IS MELANIA
MISSING?
THEY PITCHED THEIR SEGMENT AS
HOW THE MEDIA IS COVERING
MELANIA'S ABSENCE.
SO THEY ARE COVERING HOW THEY
ARE COVERING IT.
I GUESS WE SHOULD COVER HOW THEY
ARE COVERING HOW THEY ARE
COVERING IT.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE HAS BEEN
QUIET ABOUT MELANIA TRUMP AND
HER STATUS.
WE SAW HER TWEET THE OTHER DAY.
THE FIRST TIME WE CAUGHT A
GLIMPSE OF HER, THE LAST TIME WE
CAUGHT A GLIMPSE OF HER WAS ON
MAY 10.
I WONDER IF SOMEBODY IS GUIDING
THAT KIND OF TWEET FROM HER.
IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE HER, AT
LEAST THE IMAGE SHE HAS HAD IN
HER ENGAGEMENT WITH THE PRESS.
>> IF THE FIRST LADY OR THE
PERSON STANDING IN FOR THE
FIRST LADY DISAPPEARED, YOU WANT
TO KNOW WHERE SHE IS.
>> Greg: THEY EVEN HAD A
CHART.
HOW SOPHISTICATED.
THE SPECULATION FUELED AND LESS
GUESSING GAMES.
THE PLEASURE MANY FOUND AND
HOPING SOMEONE WAS WRONG --
SOMETHING WAS WRONG WITH THE
FIRST LADY AND CLOAKING IT IN
SOME KIND OF CONCERN.
CNN, "NEWSWEEK" ," THE GHOULS
BARELY HAVE ANY HUMANITY LEFT.
JUST WHEN YOU THINK YOU HIT THE
BOTTOM OF THE CESSPOOL, MORE
CESSPOOL.
SOME EVEN SUGGESTED TRUMP BEAT
MELANIA.
TRAPPED IN THEIR OWN PRISON OF
PAIN SINCE 2016, THEIR MISERY
ONLY SIX COMPANY.
JEFF ZUCKER MUST BE SPINNING IN
HIS GRAVE, IF HE WASN'T ALIVE
AND WELL.
OR IS HE?
HAS ANYONE SEEN HIM?
SEE WHAT I DID THERE?
DANA, THIS IS WHAT PEOPLE DO ON
SUNDAYS.
THERE ARE PEOPLE SITTING AROUND
TWEETING ABOUT IF TRUMP, HAS
TRUMP BEAT MELANIA.
>> Dana: IT'S REALLY GROSS.
NUMBER ONE THE MEDIA WAS UPSET
ABOUT ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT
HILLARY CLINTON'S HEALTH DURING
THE CAMPAIGN COMMAND THAT THAT
WAS OUT OF FANS.
BUT SHE DID FAINT.
SHE WANTED TO BE THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
SHE IS NOT AN ELECTED PERSON,
THE FIRST LADY, SHE CAN DO
WHATEVER SHE WANTS.
I HOPE SHE IS WELL.
IT WOULD BE MORE BELIEVABLE IF
THEY REALLY CARED HOW SHE WAS.
>> Greg: I DON'T THINK THEY
CARE.
THE THING THAT GETS ME IS THAT
CAMOUFLAGE, JUST WORRIED ABOUT
HER.
NO, YOU ARE NOT.
YOU DON'T EVEN LIKE HER.
>> Jesse: LAST WEEK THEY WERE
MAKING ALL SORTS OF DISGUSTING
COMMENTARY NOW THEY ARE SO
CONCERNED ABOUT HER HEALTH.
THE MEDIA SPENDING MORE TIME
WONDERING WHERE MELANIA IS AN
NOT WONDERING WHERE ISIS IS.
DON'T YOU THINK THEY WOULD SPILL
SOME INK OVER THAT?
TRUMP MADE ISIS DISAPPEAR.
MELANIA HASN'T GONE ANYWHERE.
PETER STRZOK WENT MISSING.
THEY HAVEN'T SHOVED A CAMERA IN
HIS FACE, SEEMS LIKE THE MEDIA
MIGHT WANT ANSWERS ABOUT HIS
WHEREABOUTS.
SHE HAD KIDNEY SURGERY THREE
WEEKS AGO.
AN INVASIVE AND DELICATE
PROCEDURE.
I'M SURE SHE WANTS TO COME BACK
ON HER OWN TERMS AT HER OWN
TIME, AND THAT'S FINE.
TRUMP'S MARRIAGES HAVE ALWAYS
BEEN SUBJECT TO TABLOID FODDER.
IT IS GOOD INK.
PEOPLE PROFIT OFF IT.
SHE IS NOT THE MOST, SHE DOESN'T
SPEAK A LOT PUBLICLY.
THERE IS A VACUUM THERE AND SHE
DOESN'T HAVE A ROBUST P.R.
MACHINE.
THEY FILL THE VOID WITH THESE
SPECULATIONS AND NARRATIVES THAT
HAVE NO CONNECTION TO REALITY.
I THINK IT SHOWS A DISRESPECT OF
THE FIRST FAMILY.
LAST TIME IT WAS IVANKA, THEN
MELANIA.
THEY DON'T RESPECT THEM LIKE
THEY USED TO.
>> Greg: >> Greg: JUAN, I
>> Greg: >> Greg: JUAN, S
>> Greg: >> Greg: JUAN, T
>> Greg: >> Greg: JUAN, I
>> Greg: >> Greg: JUAN, S
>> Greg: >> Greg: JUAN, A
>> Greg: >> Greg: JUAN, O
>> Greg: >> Greg: JUAN, H
>> Greg: >> Greg: JUAN, R
EXAMPLE, BECAUSE THIS IS SO MUCH
GOOD NEWS, YOU HAVE TO GO AFTER
THE FIRST LADY BECAUSE SHE MIGHT
BE RECUPERATING OR MAYBE SHE
JUST LIKES TO DO WHATEVER THE
HELL SHE WANTS.
>> Juan: I DON'T FOLLOW
TWITTER THE WAY YOU DO BUT I
DON'T KNOW THAT THERE'S ANY
ANTIPATHY TOWARD HER.
I HAVEN'T SEEN THAT.
>> Greg: YOU HAVEN'T SEEN
ANYONE MAKING FUN OF HER ACCENT?
>> Juan: PEOPLE HAVE SAID
THAT.
PEOPLE QUESTION HER HEALTH
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T KNOW MUCH
ABOUT THIS.
SUBSEQUENTLY, ANYONE WHO IS
SICK, YOU HAVE TO HAVE SOME
SYMPATHY FOR THEM.
THE BIG QUESTION HERE IS, SHE IS
SUPPOSED TO HAVE AN EVENT TODAY
FOR GOLD STAR FAMILIES.
THEY CLOSED IT TO THE PRESS.
AT SOME POINT, WHEN YOU ARE IN
POWER AND YOU START TO KEEP THE
PRESS OUT, THE PRESS IS LIKE,
WHAT'S GOING ON?
I THINK THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
GETTING.
YOU WANT TO ATTACK THE PRESS FOR
THIS?
I THINK AT THE WHITE HOUSE WAS
TRANSPARENT AND SAID YOU KNOW
WHAT, SHE IS 48.
SHE HAD SURGERY.
SHE WANTS TO HAVE A REST.
MAXIMIZING EVERYBODY IN AMERICA
WOULD SAY GOD BLESS HER.
I HOPE SHE IS RECOVERING WELL.
>> Greg: YOU HAVEN'T LOOKED AT
THE TWEETS.
THEY TALKED ABOUT HER GETTING
BEATEN UP.
>> Juan: WHY IS ANYBODY SAYING
THAT?
>> Greg: BECAUSE THEY ARE
AWFUL PEOPLE AND I WON'T MENTION
THEIR NAMES.
THEY WILL NOT BE MENTIONED ON
"THE FIVE," BUT YOU CAN LOOK
THEM UP.
>> Kimberly: IT'S REALLY
DISRESPECTFUL.
IT'S A SERIOUS MEDICAL
CONDITION.
SHE HAD TO GET THE KIDNEY
EMBOLIZATION, VISITED WALTER
REED.
PERHAPS SHE NEEDS TIME TO
RECOVER AND GET BACK ON HER
FEET.
SHE HAS A VERY STRESSFUL JOB
BECAUSE SHE IS NOT TREATED WELL
IN THE PRESS TO BEGIN WITH.
THERE IS AN EMOTIONAL,
PSYCHOLOGICAL STRAIN IN OUR
PHYSICAL TOLL ON HER BODY.
SHE'S A MOTHER OF A YOUNG SON,
AND SO SHE'S GOING TO SPEND TIME
AS WELL WITH HIM, QUITE WORRIED
ABOUT HIS MOM.
WHAT IS THE POINT, THEY ACTED
LIKE SHE WAS LIKE A MISSING
PERSON.
>> Greg: THIS WHITE HOUSE IS
THE MOST DESPERATE THING IN THE
HISTORY OF HISTORY.
WE KNOW EVERYTHING.
>> Dana: THEY MAKE FUN OF IT
FOR BEING A REALITY SHOW BUT
THEY THINK THIS IS PART OF THE
ACT.
THEY ARE HIDING MELANIA FROM YOU
SO YOU CAN'T SEE HER.
IT HAS TO BECOME PART OF THE
STORY LINE OR SOMETHING.
>> Kimberly: AND FEIGN
CONCERN.
WHEN THEY AREN'T ACTUALLY
CONCERNED.
IF THEY CARED, THEY WOULD